For this question, we're going to think about a table that, by the way, is a table.
On this table we're going to put a giant spring.
Here's the spring, uncompressed, not stretched, totally at equilibrium,
totally boring, so let's compress it.
The way we're going to do that is by squeezing it back a distance Δx,
and by putting a little block here with mass m, of course.
Of course--I shouldn't even have to say it--this table is frictionless.
Of course, this table has some height h and the spring has some constant, some stiffness, k.
When I squeeze this, if I let go what's going to happen?
The mass is going to fling forward and shoot off and land somewhere over here.
Your job for this question is to tell me what is this distance d.
Now, you can't answer it yet. Let me give you some numbers.
The height of the table is 2 m. The mass is 1 kg.
Δx is 25 cm--not meters.
The spring constant is 350 N/m.
That should be enough information for you to tell me what is d.
How far will this object fall from the table when it finally lands?
You can enter your answer here in meters.